[Music]
we finally hit the time of year where
games thin out the triple-a titles relax
slightly and we see games which don't
usually get the limelight May is one of
those months his seven games trying to
get your attention of a May 2019
probably the biggest game of the month
is rage - the first game back in 2011
borrowed heavily from the visuals
associated with Borderlands and the
gameplay of fallout 4 Age 2 has improved
upon this massively leaving behind the
borderlands art style and instead takes
the post-apocalyptic landscape of the
Mad Max movies and introduces so much
color and vibrancy
it doesn't feel depressing hot pink can
make you feel good alright Rach 2 is
completely single-player its open world
first-person shooter that embraces chaos
and another feather in their cap is the
relationship with Just Cause 3
developers Avalanche Studios who are on
board to bring the physics based
ridiculousness
into the world of rage if you let your
guns if you're a bit of a weapon nut
rage - has you covered with many weird
and wonderful guns melee weapons
throwables and downright destruction at
your fingertips so if you fancy
surviving a meteor destroying earth with
some superpowers at your disposal
pick up reg - on May 14th for ps4 Xbox
one and PC
next the PlayStation virtual reality PSP
R is back with another highly
anticipated game blood and truth when
PSP are first released one of the tech
demos was a cockney gangster fest the
London heist it was damn good the people
behind that experience are back with a
full-length video game in which we are
basically John wig cross with Jason
Bourne with a little bit of Ethan Hunt
and some James Bond for good measure all
wrapped up into one in virtual reality
I'm extremely happy to play this one and
hopefully a few more people invest in
psvr as there are so many games to
discover in fact I'm going to throw a
poll up do you have psvr
are you interested in trying it are you
sick of this fad let us know please in
blood and truth shooting may be the core
element that gets the headlines but the
minigames are impressive too we will
lock pit we will hack we will search for
clues so if you're ready to spy blood
and truth is available on psvr
exclusively from May 28th next we have a
potential sleeper hit a plague tale
innocence set in 14th century medieval
France in a rat filled city and when I
say rat filled I mean it they can
consume a human body in a matter of
moments the car mechanic is light the
darkness attracts the rats the light
forces them away we need to stay in the
light and manipulate enemies to light
our path although the gameplay shown so
far looks slow and menacing we're told
the action parts of the game reveal
themselves later this is added to by
puzzles utilizing light and logic in
pretty impressive and unique ways it's
hard to find information about to play
exhale innocence but from the latest
gameplay shown this is gonna be dark
horrifying and deadly a plague tale
innocence releases on ps4 PC and Xbox on
May 14th
let's lighten the mood with Sonic the
Hedgehog we all know he's fast well now
he's even faster due to the sports car
he's riding with crash team racing
coming next month sonic has jumped in to
take the limelight supporting both
split-screen and up to 12 players online
team sonic racing is the Mario Kart for
all platforms there's an added
customization element which introduces a
way to be individual and ultimately team
sonic racing is a simple arcade racer
for Speed junkies releasing on May 21st
on all major consoles and the PC to back
in 2012 Sniper Elite v2 took everything
great about the original game and took
it up a notch
who doesn't love seeing a bullet enter a
man and tear his spine into pieces I
realize that makes me sound like a
madman but it's addicting now in 2019 we
have a remastered version with updated
graphics 4k support better frame rates
all the DLC and a few new characters too
let's be honest here it's all about
finding Hitler and seeing if the rumors
are true if you know what I mean
especially v2 remastered drops on May
14th on ps4 Xbox one twitch and PC did
you know that Konami
is celebrating their 50th anniversary
this year to commemorate they are
releasing anniversary collections one of
which is Castlevania for an ultra cheap
price relive eight Castlevania titles
going as far back as 1987 damn
the snez version is here too so is the
Game Boy it's a retro masterclass but
they look far better in your memory than
they do in real life still awesome
though May 16th
if you're interested
and finally again for Shia horror fans
layers of fear to the first layers of
fear game released about three years ago
and scared the [ __ ] out of everyone who
played now gun media are on board there
are people behind Friday the 13th the
game laser fear too looks to be more
realistic and much more polished
we should result in mafia in more jump
scares and so so much blood fancy trying
it together let me know your thoughts I
would explain the story but I feel it's
best to going blind to get the full
experience here layers of fear to will
release on May 28th on ps4 Xbox and PC
with a switch version coming later down
the line so there we have it 7 new games
for May 20 19 what the heck you're
grabbing blood and truth and layers of
fear too for me just for watching which
appreciate it come talk to me on Twitter
I'm Adam granade I'll see you soon ha
[Music]